Speaker 1: . Mike Pence is
going to have a CNN town hall.
But he's not a candidate for the presidency.
So what on earth is going on? Let's see if we
can figure it out. CNN has announced that on June
7th, there will be a Republican presidential town
hall with Vice President Mike Pence. What are
you going to do, A town hall with a guy who's
not a candidate? What on earth is going on? And
it even says that Pence is going to take questions
from Iowa Republicans and Iowa voters who will be
participating in the Republican caucuses. But he
hasn't said he's running. Well, there is a KCCI
Yahoo life Yahoo News report. We never know who's
reporting this. Former Vice President Mike Pence
lays the groundwork for a 2024 presidential run.
In Des Moines. In Des Moines. It is increasingly
looking like former Vice President Mike Pence is
going to be running against the guy he served
under Donald Trump, which is stunning. Now,
is it unprecedented? No. There are a couple other
examples of vice presidents running against the
president they served under. I don't have them in
front of me. But we're going to if Pence becomes
a candidate, we will look at that in more detail.
If you thought that this primary was going to get
ugly with the entrance of Ron DeSantis against
Donald Trump, and it is already getting very
ugly because of that. Just you wait until
Mike Pence gets in. Now, interestingly,
Mike Pence is in third place right now.
Right now, the Trump decline since the
DeSantis announcement continues, the DeSantis
bump since the announcement continues, Trump
down to 54. DeSantis up to 21. But Mike Pence is
basically tied with Nikki Haley just under 5%.
Now, does Mike Pence really have a shot at
becoming the Republican nominee? I don't believe
so. But to the extent that Trump gets triggered
by so-called disloyalty, you can imagine no more
disloyal action from your own former vice
president than that vice president saying,
I actually think I would be so much better for the
country than you. Even though I served alongside
you that I am going to run against you. So this
is going to be listen to the town hall is going
to be Mike Pence. Not exactly electrifying
the crowd. Mike Pence, lacking charisma,
almost as acutely as Ron DeSantis. And the event
itself is not really something that I'm super
interested in. But but the fact that it's sort
of an event for a presidential candidate, even
though he's not actually a presidential candidate,
really points to a fascinating situation that we
will be following extraordinarily closely.
That's June 7th. Mike Pence, I guess,
looking like he's going to run against Trump.
Just wait till you see Trump fly off the handle